hey guys i am just mcdonald it's the
27th of march and you're watching the
games but news let's make blood pictures
first up dev on dev cattiness is back in
our lives again and today it's minecraft
notch vs. cliff bleszinski the guy that
made years of war referring to not just
comments about no longer wanting to
bring minecraft to oculus because
facebook creeps him out cliff is called
the dev a pouty kid he referred to
nachos decision as a bratty and petty
move within a lengthy blog post about
the Facebook acquisition of oculus it's
probably also worth a mention that
bleszinski has a pretty large stake in
oculus as a result of chipping in
venture capital and he himself has
pointed out that he stares to make a
buttload of money off of Facebook spy
out cliff also criticized what he called
the internet outrage machine clearly
referring to the swarms of very unhappy
consumers who don't want the Facebook
made oculus let me know whether you are
not a clevy side on this one the last of
us could be making an appearance on ps4
is a video on the Turkish CNN video game
website multiplayer is to be believed
while we're all happy that multiplayer
has had its first big break in the
industry it's all thanks to the
PlayStation Turkey BP star in salon who
claimed in a video on this site that the
action title would come to ps4 as a
physical and digital release salon said
the wireless sequel is not in the works
this is the next big thing to look
forward to for the last of us fans at
this stage the news has not been
confirmed by Sony but we'll be bringing
you updates as a story on rival last up
respawn is the new sheriff in town and
those caught cheating on titan falls pc
version well soon wish they hadn't the
dev have officially started enforcing
bands for players caught cheating as
detected by anti cheat engine fair fight
gamers who are refusing to play nice
will be banned and will subsequently see
this image they'll still be able to play
the game but it seems they could well be
a fate worse than titanfall exile
because they'll be banished to join a
server pool comprised solely of other
cheaters respawn are calling this the
Wimbledon of aimbot contest and a
wishing Cheetahs luck laced with sarcasm
saying hopefully the aimbot cheat you
paid
really is the best all these old cheetah
matches could be frustrating for you
good luck if you've been banned and want
to play games with your non band pals
for that specific session everyone in
your party will be treated as a band
player henceforth suddenly making you a
really really unpopular person to play
titanfall with do you guys reckon this
is anti-cheating gone mad or are you
happy to see the Isle of cheaters arise
you can let me know your thoughts in
that comment section down below or on my
Twitter where I'm at just MacDonald that
is all the good stuff for me today but
tomorrow I've got my top 5 news stories
of the whole entire gaming week so I do
have to see you again then